non
et
là on écoute non
[Musique]
c'est bon
super le spécial
two maison qui était musicien mes grands
parents aussi donc il ya un nom à
respecter si tu veux tu appelles fanfan
bah tu fais de la musique et suffit de
la musique tu fais bien sinon tu fais
pas de musique one
[Musique]
du fait d'être en france assez lent de
la guadeloupe surtout avec le décalage
de mon âge l'héritage que j'ai de mon
grand-père en fait c'est vraiment des
archives c'est à dire que y'a les
disques il ya les documents mon grand
père a été décoré alors mon nom jouer
avec les légions d'honneur on joue aux
soldats et ont joué aussi avec les
galettes de disques 78 tours qu'on a
fini par casser évidemment donc moi j'ai
j'avais cette image du grand père qui
nous laissait des morceaux au moins nous
laisser une trace donc il y avait les 70
tours il y avait des morceaux connus
tout ça m'est arrivé souvent mia c'est
ton grand père qui a fait ça mais c'est
très connu sa semence aulas est clair
[Musique]
pas
il a voulu rassurant
[Musique]